on était parti seul entre filles sans
parents et pour la première fois j'avais
eu un petit copain je parlais pas
italien il parle pas français de toute
façon j'aimais pas parler
[Musique]
le téléphone tu connais super le retour
de vacances année bien
[Musique]
tu passes le Back cette année
au café comme ta mère bah pourquoi
qu'est-ce que tu aimes bien faire après
l'école je fais de la danse super quel
genre de danse
[Musique]
cassée avec une conne
tu veux quoi pour ton anniv rien rien ça
coûte pas cher
[Musique]
et
la vie
il y a les deux morues qui se foutent de
ma gueule
c'est une star
chacun pour sa gueule
il y a une fac de danse ça peut être
super c'est bon les études tu passes ton
bac puis tu cherches un travail
[Musique]
je crois que je suis amoureuse de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]